située près de la frontière alsacienne
lachapelle sous rougemont 400 habitants
dont linda et alain il y a deux ans ils
ont installé une microbrasserie dans
leur garage deux à trois fois par mois
après leurs heures de travail
le couple brasse et met en bouteille
l'année dernière
on a fait la fête des voisins et puis on
s'est dit tiens on va ramener un peu de
bière pour faire goûter tout le monde a
adoré puis on s'est dit pourquoi pas on
espérait bien faire quelque chose quoi
et du coup après on a commencé à faire
les démarches pour vous une entreprise
si brassée à lachapelle sous rougemont
est un hasard pour eux c'est en revanche
une bonne nouvelle pour le village car
au 19e siècle la commune abriter l'une
des plus importantes brasseries du
département la brasserie grise est
fondée en 1806 françois grise et
fabrique de la bière pour la
consommation familiale ce qui est au
départ de l'amateurisme devient très
vite une affaire prospère plus de 40
salariés y travaillent en 1962 faute de
repreneur l'entreprise ferme ses portes
soixante ans plus tard la bière de linda
et alain est donc un véritable clin
d'oeil à ce passé historique
on essaie de retrouver une petite
recette de de l'ancienne brasserie pour
les anciens parce qu'on sait que les
anciens sont très attachés à cette
ancienne brasserie
tout le monde nous parle toujours de
l'ancienne activité de cette brasserie
serait que nous à notre échelle c'est
minime
on est vraiment microscopique par
rapport à l'activité qui avait
auparavant mais on espère que ça va
fonctionner que ça va plaire aux gens
parmi les gens déjà conquis il y à
l'ancien maire amateurs de bière et
grand connaisseur de la crise et il se
réjouit du retour de cette activité
c'est pas financièrement pas intéressant
mais par contre j'ai un peu c'est
inventer à nouveau la bière coin donc
avec tout le patrimoine que la brasserie
a laissé derrière elle
c'est bien c'est marrant je leur
souhaite bonne chance à ce jeune couple
est bon courage et prospérité pour cette
bière qui portent joliment son nom la
bière de la chapelle